[Music]
we would like to think that Disney fans
love all the movies that have been
created by the company but you'll be
surprised to see that this is just
impossible - like some of these stories
the reason why you never heard about
them as they went straight to DVD stay
tuned to see how the true story of
Pocahontas
ended up being worse than what we ever
imagined if you love Disney as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you the 10 worst
straight-to-dvd Disney sequels The
Little Mermaid 2 returned to the sea The
Little Mermaid is still one of the most
popular movies more than 25 years after
it's been released
it was the story of Ariel a young
mermaid who was fascinated by the human
world her father told her not to go near
these men but the redhead didn't listen
to him and even became a human herself
this was how she got the chance to meet
Prince Erik and the two quickly fell in
love fast-forward over a decade and the
two lovers have a daughter melody this
is where the story of the Little Mermaid
- returned to the sea began this time
the young girl wanted to swim in the
ocean but Ariel kept her from going
anywhere near the water because she was
afraid of what Ursula's sister could do
to her
like mother like daughter melody ended
up breaking the rules and becoming
transformed into a mermaid the story had
a lot of potential but unfortunately it
could never be as good as the first
movie fans had already seen the original
story and seen a reverse of the main
plot of the first movie was one of the
reasons why they hated this
straight-to-dvd sequel and just because
they couldn't learn from their mistake
Disney released a third film The Little
Mermaid
Ariel's beginning that was just as bad
as the second one Cinderella - dreams
come true if you have ever heard about
this film don't change anything your
life is perfect like that but for those
who are curious to see how Cinderella
story could end up so badly we're here
to tell you what this movie was about in
the original movie Cinderella a poor
girl raised as a servant had a chance to
go to the ball and this is when the
Prince fell in love with her and changed
her life forever
this story was so popular that it
inspired many rags-to-riches stories
including a Cinderella story with Hilary
Duff and unn
Cinderella story with Selena Gomez but
when Disney decided to give another
chance to character of the original
movie from 1950 they quickly regretted
it in Cinderella - dreams come true
the princess was already happily ever
after so she didn't have a lot of things
to care about other than planning a
party however we were surprised to see
one of her stepsisters Anastasia falling
in love with a low-class man that her
mother didn't approve of the movie cost
only 5 million dollars to produce and it
became the top-selling animated sequel
that year grossing one hundred and
twenty million dollars but just because
people paid to see the movie didn't mean
they liked watching it but there was
still some money to make so Disney
released a third film Cinderella three a
twist in time that could never be better
than the original movie The Hunchback of
Notre Dom - based on Victor Hugo's novel
notre-dame de Paris the story had a lot
of potential it was adapted to make it
more appropriate for children and a new
generation got the chance to discover
these famous character in The Hunchback
of Notre Dom Quasimodo a deformed bell
ringer struggled to be accepted by
society
he and Esmeralda became friends and just
like any other man he quickly fell in
love with her
however he finally had to accept that
she was in love with Phoebus and gave
them his blessing two years later we had
the chance to see Quasimodo and
Esmeralda in one of the best French
musicals we've ever seen but
unfortunately their story could have
never been better than it already was
Quasimodo tried to come back under the
spotlight in the Hunchback of Notre Dom
- this time Phoebus and Esmeralda had a
son and Quasimodo finally met his
soulmate
we were happy for the Hunchback but
viewers certainly did not fall in love
with a movie people catch criticizing
for animation the weak songs and the
dull millet fans even went as far saying
that it was one of Disney's worst films
describing it as a cash cow with no
heart or soul so Quasimodo was found
love but once again he was not really
appreciated by everyone The Lion King -
Simba's pride the Lion King was one of
every kid's favorite movie we all cried
when Mufasa passed away and his son
thought that it was his fault and this
is
we followed Simba on his journey away
from home but this little lion couldn't
always run away from his path and when
he had the courage to come back to fight
for justice Simba finally became the
rightful king and continued the circle
of life but that was not the end of his
story usually we love to think that our
favorite characters are happily ever
after and we are not asking for anything
more
but Disney decided to show us a little
more and this is why they released the
straight-to-dvd sequel The Lion King -
Simba spray in this movie Simba's
daughter Chiara fell in love with kobu a
lion raised in a pride of scars
followers and the two lovers fought to
stay together no matter what their
family thought it's fun to see that the
first movie was inspired by Hamlet and
the second film was based on Romeo and
Juliet - plays written by Shakespeare
but most viewers had already seen that
famous story - many times and they were
disappointed by the movie it didn't help
when Disney came back with a film no one
ever asked for the Lion King
one and a half Beauty and the Beast be
enchanted Christmas when we see how
great Beauty and the Beast was we could
imagine it could only get better now
threw herself behind bars to save her
father from the Beast
and as she lived trapped in the castle
she discovered that this creature could
be beautiful on the inside if he worked
a little bit on his personality and this
is how she helped him become her prince
charming Disney fans loved the story so
much though he even loved to watch it a
second time with the live-action movie
with Emma Watson but what has she been
up to now that her partner is perfect
the way he is we'll never know because
Beauty and the Beast the enchanted
Christmas was a middle that focused on
what happened during the original movie
after the fight with the wolves and
before the ballroom dance in this movie
the beasts forbade Christmas because it
was that time of year that he turned
into a monster this is why Belle and her
friends tried to convince him that it
was a good holiday
however as everyone knew how their fairy
tale would end they were just making the
same story too long for nothing and just
to give Mick quills another try
Disney also released Beauty and the
Beast bells magical world we hope that
they won't be making this mistake again
Mulan - we were tired of seeing
beautiful and kind Disney Princesses
falling in love with a prince this time
we wanted to see a woman who was truly a
hero of her own story and this is why we
were happy to see that Disney created
Mulan just for us this young woman
wasn't born to be a housewife and she
couldn't even pretend to be one this is
why she decided to dress as a man and
join the army even if it was forbidden
by the law at that time but we bet that
people change their mind when they saw
Mulan save her country she was a proud
and independent woman and this is why
fans were disappointed by Mulan too in
this story Shang proposed to Mulan and
she accepted to be his fiancee then they
went on a mission to his sport three
princesses who had to marry princess but
they couldn't keep them from finding
love on their way to the neighboring
kingdom in the end the princesses broke
their vows and Mulan and Shang finally
got the chance to get married but fans
were expecting another kind of happily
ever after formal on her favorite hero
was turned into another young woman
whose life was changed by her prince
charming
we wish Disney could offer something a
little different than that Tarzan to the
legend began we were all fascinated by
the world of Tarzan after escaping a
shipwreck and losing his parent a young
boy was raised by a gorilla and this is
how he grew up in nature surrounded by
his friends the animals Jane was
surprised to see this man who knew
nothing of the modern world
but that didn't keep the two from
falling in love and living in the jungle
together this time we have to admit that
we wanted to see what would happen to
the couple this is not a happily ever
after like anything we've ever seen
before Jane won't be living a beautiful
life in a castle but facing the dangers
of nature and we were curious to see
what would happen in the second movie
this is why we were a little bit
disappointed to see that Tarzan to the
legend begins was actually a prequel the
film told the story of a young Tarzan
who went on an adventure to discover who
he truly was the boy felt like he didn't
fit in and realized by the end of the
movie that being unique didn't keep him
from being a part of his family the
movie wasn't that bad after all
and it was praised for the decent
animation quality but everyone agreed on
one thing this pre-poll was not
necessary Bambi
to Bambi was a movie that any child
would remember forever and it's not only
because it was good but because we were
shocked to see what happened to Bambi's
mother after she had passed away we
follow the little fawn on his journey to
become the new great Prince of the
forest and watch over the animals like
his parents used to watch over him
we saw Bambi growing up during the whole
movie but Disney felt like there was
something missing they wanted to show
him growing up even more this is why
they released Bambi to a mid pool that
took place between the moment that the
fawn lost his mother and before he grew
into a buck this time we thought Bambi
growing up in the care of his father who
taught him how to survive in the forest
but the young fawn had a lot of things
to teach him - Bambi - held one record
it was for having the longest period of
time between the original movie and the
middle more than 60 years but even
though the newest film was praised for
the animation characters and voice
acting it could never be better than the
first one
sometimes things do not get better in
time even though it was probably one of
the best straight-to-dvd sequels we
think that sometimes one is better than
two the return of Jafar Aladdin was
everyone's favorite movie when we were
kids girls love to see the beautiful
Disney Princess boys loved the action
and those who don't care about gender
stereotypes just loved everything about
it it was the story of a thief with a
heart of gold who was ready to do
anything to win the love of Princess
Jasmine luckily for him he had a genie
to make three of his wishes come true
but Aladdin finally realized that he
didn't need all these things to make her
fall in love with him because Jasmine
loved him as he truly was this story had
so much potential that we had to see
another one this time the villain would
get much more attention in the return of
Jafar he tried to gain revenge on
Aladdin jasmine and their friends to
become the ruler of Agrabah if you think
that you're just re watching the first
movie you'd be wrong it just seems like
some people never change and this is why
many viewers were disappointed
the story was too repetitive fans also
criticized that Disney put very little
effort
to the production of the movie and it
clearly showed the following sequel
Aladdin and the king of thieves with a
little better but it could never be as
great as the original movie better luck
next time Disney Pocahontas to journey
to a new world when people watch the
first movie Pocahontas many people
criticize that it didn't represent what
actually happened according to Disney
the Native American woman and John Smith
were curious to know more about each
other's world they even fell in love
protected each other and into being
separated but the true story is darker
than what anyone could ever imagine and
it certainly was not family-friendly
Disney could have had the chance to fix
their mistake in Pocahontas to journey
to a new world
this time Englishman came back to
America for negotiation
Pocahontas accepted to travel to Europe
with John Rolfe to speak to the king to
prevent the war but on her journey the
Native American hero ended up falling in
love with Rolfe the movie was met with
negative reviews from critics and we
certainly understand why once again it
was far from what actually happened to
Pocahontas and we can tell you that it
was not a love story at all for the poor
Native American this tragedy is not
something that would be turned into a
fairy tale to make more money once again
Disney couldn't make only one mistake
but had to make - to learn from it is
there any Disney movie that would
deserve a good sequel don't forget to
tell us more about it in the comment
section below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 worst
straight-to-dvd Disney sequels for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
deleted Disney Princesses and reject a
concept thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]